hello hello hello how are you how you
feeling it is time to dig in a sims's
film vault he's watched more games this
week than maybe ever before think so
how's that big brain of your sisters
fried I was gonna say it's been a very
tired week Josh looked at me yesterday
and said I think Sims is dying
I think your brain is scrambled it is a
little I think you're just a little
screwed up this week yeah is it week
five is it is it yeah week six it's just
you know it's a lot and then there's
always extra thrown on the plate well
some of the next on the plate may have
been a latke it may have been some LOX
maybe a matzo ball soup if you haven't
seen it yet Wednesday 8:00 p.m. we gave
to reek Cowan a bear mitzvah let's just
say it ends with us doing the hora and
lifting him on a chair while he's
wearing a bear's yarmulke giving a
million I would say easily the peak of
my career I don't know about you but I
don't think it's getting better for me
the shirt that Fenwick's wearing let's
take that off all your microphones in
the way just quiet that's nice it is for
you Sam thank you appreciate that didn't
I give you one the other day you did and
you're not wearing no I didn't I took it
home though at this home give it to the
kids yeah give it to the kids big moment
Monday night drew brees passes Brett
Favre Annie Pratt passes Peyton Manning
yeah he currently stands at 70 2103
before we talk about the moment yeah how
many yards do you think Brees ends with
do you think I heard some people say he
could definitely get one or two I could
see Brees play in a year or two more I
think so too
I could see Brees getting close to
80,000 probably I mean let's see this
year were a quarter the way through
he's probably what somewhere in the 1500
range right now
yes he's going to be close he could be
around 75,000 by the year he certainly
could not the way that you could pass in
today's NFL exactly he's thrown for 1658
yards this year yes 300 last year 5200
so he's definitely to go over 4,000 this
year and we know that and it's just
gonna be whether it's low 4,000
hi for thousands and yeah he's two more
years he's gonna fall just short of
80,000 which is amazing it's it didn't
think it was possible like with that
with the way Peyton looked when I was
finishing his career right I didn't
think it'd be possible no what did you
think of the moment the moment was
amazing I mean to do it in that kind of
style what's that was awesome it's the
dream it really is and then our boy Dave
Baker was there to take away the ball
and say I will protect this with the
shank totry of the guy he was wearing
white gloves when he took oh I mean the
man really sells a moment I mean it was
cool though and I also find it fitting
that the guy was wide open along the
sideline and ran in for a touchdown
I just mean I texted you guys I said I
think it's fitting that half of his
yards tonight are coming off of screen
oh it's alright hey Don no no he's he's
again we don't hate on him it's not
about hate nobody hates we just say he's
not the top but I'm just we're just
being that kind of either way we're just
keeping it real he was a hotel he was
amazing the other night he certainly was
and it's well deserved and I'm glad he's
getting all the credit that he's getting
I thought his moment with his sons where
he pulled them around and says you could
achieve anything if you work hard loved
it yeah you know the fact that they got
him miked up did I think ESPN did a good
job no because I'll tell you that ESPN
on Monday Night Football in did a good
job
pretty bad it's hey let's do that moment
one more time guys I've seen it seven
three times already I know but man I
went on a radio station in Toronto and
they were like breezes top five all-time
right and I was like no he's just not
and and they were like what and we got
to the conversation and I said look like
Elway did it with nobody Marino did it
with nobody like look at the help that
Drew Brees has had like look at all the
weapons around look at the coaches and
it's a bigger conversation how do you
separate an all-time great player from
his all-time great coach right it's
weird that Jordan doesn't get mentioned
with Phil Jackson but Kobe gets
mentioned with Phil Jackson to go across
sports but Joe Montana well he had Bill
Walsh one of the premier white collars
of all time right Oh Terry Bradshaw
Chuck Noll you know you can't separate
those guys right Bill Belichick and Tom
Brady I mean that's gonna be an issue
for
forty years I get it but Sean Payton and
Drew Brees do you separate how do you
figure out you versa I don't think you
can bear basketball right basketball and
one player can change the game meaning
literally I mean LeBron goes to one team
and all sudden you go well they're one
of the favorites to the finals it
doesn't work like that in football yes
separating it is really hard to do it
really is and it takes a trained ID to a
degree I would I would argue that it
takes somebody that understands true
concepts of football and play calling
and things like that and I'm not trying
to jomini anybody I'm trying to sit here
on a pedestal and be like oh I played
the game
oh I joined the game and you didn't I I
get that I'm not but but I also need to
take like some credit for being taught
by some really smart people and offenses
and I being around NFL quarterbacks my
whole life I have a new take yeah that
you could do that not a lot of athletes
can but I don't think you having played
the game helps you I think you
understanding how to watch a game helps
you definitely that's what I think fans
don't understand right everybody can
look at a football game and see a
50-yard touchdown by Drew Brees and go
he's good the receiver is good the
defense is bad right which is I feel
like how fans watch the game right but
you are looking at keys you'll come away
from a first half with different notes
than just a fan watching it you know how
to watch it and I don't think that's
even just from playing it I think it's
from how you learned how to study film
yeah no I think that's a huge part of it
my times and rooms with Gruden day after
day and josh mcdaniels and breaking down
film with the Patriots and then hey
knowing what's realistic to ask of a
quarterback because I did get to
experience that to a degree and know
what's easy and what's not easy for a
quarterback having you know the fact
that I've been on the field with people
like Drew Brees many times and Tom Brady
and Aaron Rodgers and I've seen Brett
Favre play right in front of me two
different times so what does that allow
you this I mean it allows me to see
their physical greatness or their
differences in physicality in person
which TV is not always going to do
justice a lot of people would say that
bruises strength is not all physical
right
breezes ability to see the field breezes
comprehension of the PlayBook breeze his
ability to be a coach on the field yeah
how would you respond to that God Stefan
would respond any one of the great
quarterbacks in the history of football
have all those qualities just that's not
greater in that than it then the the
lways the Mannings no Favre
no not at all no and and in fact I would
say that's where I would go well Sean
Payton lessons that argument cuz he just
goes here's Mark Ingram wide open three
yards but now we're back to discussion
so so you know that it's more Sean
Payton than Drew Brees because of I I
know it's more short because of the
amount of easy completions that are
given the different formations all the
creative plays I watch every weekend go
oh that was cool the ability to verge
Sean Payton to dial up screens and you
go damn is he just lucky or is he dial
up the screen against the most perfect
defense every time and so it's all those
things added to the fact of also would I
always go back to what do you do when
the play isn't perfect what do you do
when the play is not perfect and that's
always gonna happen to any quarterback
on any team a few times a game and you
don't think Brees when it breaks down I
think he's good he's not special I would
say he's a double all-time greats he's
definitely not in the class of some of
the other all-time greats when it comes
to that I mean we also saw Brady on
Thursday night right video came out for
him like our new favorite guy be like Oh
what an incredible three yard pass by
Tom great right there was like 15 to 20
plays sheriff quick little check downs
sure but I also when I'm watching that I
go you know you need the right conductor
to organize that yeah execute yeah and
it's so it's this weird thing where you
need a guy to be like super polished at
that right you know what drew brees his
completion percentage of this season 70
to 78 yeah
he's damn near 80 like we freaked out
when Sam Bradford broke 72 years ago
he's at 78% yeah it's it's amazing and
he's an incredible passer and he's a
really good athlete and he does
everything really good am i shocked that
he is throwing for over seven
not in the slightest again I would say
any of the 50 top 15 quarterbacks in
football we right now would throw for
70% of that offense and it's not a shot
at him any of them would but hey yes is
he worth another 5 or 6% because of his
timing anticipation yes you know
knowledge of the offense all of that but
again I mean you watch the game the
other night and again I'm not trying to
take away but how many times were people
widel did you really make how many
throws that he did you go away from that
game go oh man look at that throw whoa
that was he was under pressure and he
fit that one into a tight window we
didn't say that one time people say he
hasn't done that people more comment on
how quickly he gets a slant and how
quickly gets it out of his hands yeah I
think we've talked about numbers and how
they're deceiving so many times jpp gets
six sacks in one game and then the end
of the year he's got like ten and a half
sacks and people forget that like right
60% of it happened in one game and not a
lot happened the rest of the year so
when you see breezes numbers now it's
gonna be impossible to argue we've said
this about Phil Simms getting the Hall
of Fame the ship has probably sailed
yeah I mean because these numbers are
gonna be absurd numbers are all they're
all gonna be absurd they're all gonna go
through the roof I mean it's it like I
would say I would say it's an easy 20 15
20 thousand extra yards that the New Age
quarterback gets to see so and one guy
that's gonna benefit from it admitted it
Tom Brady called today's NFL glorified
college football yeah he said I think
football now removing some of the
physical elements of the game it's more
of a space game you see a lot of College
plays more in the pro game than what I
remember when I started that's how it's
gone over the last bunch of years yes do
you see that - yes certainly I mean it's
it's my biggest complaint I mean when
Landon Collins almost intercepts a pass
and the ball goes through his hands and
they call the penalty on him what I
would argue ago that should have been
defenseless receiver on Devin Funchess
for hitting Landon Collins I mean that
that's of course Tom Brady's right Tom
Brady played in the era when he won his
first three Superbowl hundred yards and
the defense held you know 17 right and
then it was and then it was also like
hey Tom it's a big play we
need you to throw a 40-yard strike here
and he would deliver that's the way Troy
Aikman played in the 90s and people are
always gonna look back and go well his
stuffs aren't very good well yeah he was
asked to do a whole different set of
things but it is an interesting
conversation it's where I do think size
is gonna be playing out of the game at
the quarterback position it's gonna
slowly be pushed out because it just
doesn't matter the game space what's
wear and tear on your body anymore you
can't even hit the quarterback so who
cares if you're 6-foot 175 pounds who
cares
I mean if you get touched that's 1st
down let's go keep the change
no it also benefit more or less athletic
receivers that are maybe better at
reading zone coverages yeah it's it's
certain to be honest you can lead all of
it all all to that I mean I don't even
know where I want to go at this point
either way hey listen taught drew brees
this is what I want that that is a
verbal Wiley coyote it is I want to
button it up with the drew brees
conversation like the Drew Brees
conversation do I want I'm not gonna sit
here and just go he's definitely top 10
all-time he's in that conversation he's
somewhere between 8 and 12 8 in the
words of Simms he's a legend of the game
he's a legend of the game he's a
first-ballot hall-of-famer
I'm not deny he won one Super Bowl to
bother Bob to to use a quote from you
that you said a few weeks ago tell me
that I think says it all tell me baby
it's not a crime for some reason if the
Saints only win one Super Bowl with Drew
Brees but for whatever reason it's a
crime if Green Bay Packers no with Aaron
Rodgers everybody within that comment
right there is telling you how much
better Aaron Rodgers is but they don't
really want to admit it or deal with it
but but I was on a radio station they
were like man but he's so consistent I
go yeah you know what he's consistent
yeah you went 11 and 5 last year you
know what he was the three years before
seven and nine seven and nine seven and
nine that's where no one ever got upset
about it because and there we go right
yeah but drew never had a defense Peyton
Manning never had a [ __ ] defense for
a decade and nobody said [ __ ] they just
said he got he he'd be messed up against
the Patriots the players defenseman
glass no nobody seems to give him that
excuse so Paula have you ever seen the
juries over clap two things
third thing have you ever seen the Drew
Brees Oprah clap course when she thinks
he's got a smudge right oh I know if you
if there's some people that haven't seen
it just type in Drew Brees Oprah and
Oprah thinks that Drew Brees has
lipstick on his cheek as early as
Germany's is amazing as everybody wants
to make him right and he's still awesome
man it's hard not to have this guy you
can have a real conversation about this
I mean San Diego wouldn't have pushed
him out the door for Philip Rivers I
mean if it was at the shoulder injury it
wasn't that it was they were pushing him
out regardless he was gonna be done
because they were the most talented team
in football we weren't gonna go to the
playoffs so they were like Marty
Schottenheimer wanted to move on they
were gonna blame Drew Brees again and
Drew Brees was as awesome as he is right
now
why were the Saints gonna take Patrick
mahomes until the Chiefs turn it up in
front of him if the Saints took Patrick
mahomes what would be happening right I
don't know it's too hard to say I have a
hard time thinking the New Orleans is
gonna abandon ship after being in the
final eight last year okay
he's still awesome he still can win the
Super Bowl they have the best a line in
the sport maybe certainly in the convo
you know we talked about Shawn pay to
have a great receiving corps and running
back core here's my big thing with this
okay wheels down today I'm not going to
put Drew Brees in front of these people
at any point and I don't care if he
throws for and wins another Super Bowl
and has ten more thousand yards I don't
think he ends up with 90,000 yards
passing he is never going to be in front
of Aaron Rodgers John Elway Tom Brady
Manning which one Payton okay Marino
Favre Montana and I'm not putting him in
front of Terry Bradshaw
there's no way never Terry Bradshaw
threw for two hundred and twelve career
touchdowns in a time when people were
throwing for a hundred and forty for the
queries and they were going to whoa
that's amazing
he even at 70s he threw for 212 career
touchdowns and played a style where they
were like running on first running out
saying hey Terry its third and 12 do you
mind throwing a Louisiana bomb for us
and he'd go here Jones don't work
here's one yeah so again it's the
context about the gameplay
oh he gets the slants out so quick
because they're wide open every time it
goes back into that and I could say
these same things about Tom Brady it's
hard to balance this conversation for a
Breezer Warren Moon that's another
that's that would be somebody who'd be
in the conversation for it with hoof
fries or Johnny Unitas it's another guy
exactly right I tried not to get into
the too old Breezer Jim Kelly it's very
close I'll say that I think I would
certainly take before you said freezer
Steve Young you said who would you say
before Johnny Unitas I said Jim Kelly
Johnny Unitas what was it was Warren
Moon oh I mean I warn mood that would be
very close I would take what Roger
Staubach is in that conversation Roger
Staubach went to four Super Bowls he won
two he is the guy who scrambled around
and made plays like no other but what
his career stat like everybody dance
without ever breeze I would probably
take drew okay Dan's in that convo there
yeah I mean but yet you're saying that
you're making my pointer I would put Big
Ben I was similar in that class I mean
okay so it's what I mean the winnings
important for some arguments and then
other arguments it's not and I think
that's what frustrates me I think what
we've learned today is Sims as a hidest
he does not like quarterbacks that are
not yeah that's what I love Russell
Wilson was one of the last year to say
Baker Mayfield deserves to be in the
first round conversation you did you
know but I think it's I think it's
fascinating because the love affair with
drew you know where I think it really
stems from what when his kid wore the
headphones during the Super Bowl
when it was too loud right it was the
first time we saw that and it was the
most adorable picture ever it's the
reason he got on oh we should love Drew
Brees
it's amazing rooting for the Saints we
love love Sean Payton - yeah I'm rooting
for them I'm just trying to keep it real
I mean I I am keeping it real goes wrong
I'm saying the truth of as a career is
or my father or anybody else but
it's just it's so sensitive this subject
holy cow it's weird
other side of the game yeah Josh Norman
apparently benched in the second half
got into a fight with Michael Thomas on
Twitter because Michael Thomas was like
I put him on the bench a little
statistic here according to pro Football
Focus a perfect passer rating is 158
point three yeah Josh norming is
allowing a 156 point three and so what's
up with Josh Norman
I mean tell the truth we gotta get that
clip
dude the truth well he's never been a
shut down man-to-man corner I don't know
why everybody is taking so long to come
along with us if they've listened to us
back in 2015 when they were winning the
Superbowl in Carolina we were trying to
tell everybody that year he never
follows the best receiver the Odell
Beckham jr. Josh Norman matchup was a
farce I mean it was a it's if Odell
lined up on Josh's nice zone yeah is he
not a good zone no no he's he's screwing
up I mean there's no other way to say
what do you mean well I mean we could
either talk about the record-breaking
touchdown we're you know hey they motion
to a set they found a flaw in the
Redskins defense and expose it I mean
three of the big pass plays of that
football game came from the same play I
mean and the Redskins screwed it up all
three times and is it Josh Norman no it
was not Josh Norman it was Josh Norman
once other time I'm not sure if it was
Dunbar on the other side or swear injure
was tough to tell but you know you said
that he was supposed to drop back but
for some reason stayed in the flat
record they cover two they were playing
covered two and he's supposed to take
the flat but there must have been a
coverage adjustment when the motion came
across and now made it went from a two
by two set to a three by one set and
they were going to cover three and he
still sat there and played cover two
also on the goal line touchdown in the
back of the end zone not a hundred
percent sure but pretty sure that was
Josh Norman's fault too at least where
does Josh Norman rank at the NFL right
oh gosh it's way down the list I mean
he's in the tens over in the 2000 yeah
yeah we're down in the 20s for sure and
he's being paid 75 yes which was a
ridiculous contract to begin with again
I wouldn't you can't
pay any zone corner that kind of money
yes you can't I will say this though
yeah that is what we call good marketing
at Josh Norman a maximized his value by
being one of the rare defensive players
to to be a household name in Carolina
yeah that's incredible I know the way he
made himself available going on Dancing
with the Stars I mean that was even
after the right act but he has a
personality he's got a good twang and he
saw Odell could be my ticket yeah
remember I was with him the day that he
found out he was going to Washington
right and the reason he chose Washington
is because he's in the NFC East yeah and
the NFC sketch on TV all the time yeah
how many times he see Dallas in
Philadelphia this Thursday night the
Philadelphia Eagles take on the New York
Giants I mean the Titans can't even get
an actual broadcasting duo that I've
heard of let's go to Steve mica meek and
Bob Turner and you're like I don't know
who these guys are but Tennessee Buffalo
Steve mica mica girls a good game
hi grace he goes mash he he calls like a
19 sporty gang sorry I held on yeah look
at one thing because he's still the
highest-paid corner in football which is
hilarious at 15 million a year okay and
I just want to see what if cuz I would
think just common knowledge would be
that they can get out of this contract
after this year by the way I looked
the Giants Eli is only six million
dollars of dead cabinet here and that's
exactly what Josh Norman is so so you're
telling me that next year Eli and Josh
Norman could both be cut they could be
yeah yeah that's well it's a fun game to
play which star could be cut next year
yeah I would think that I mean all you
have to do is listen to the Monday night
telecasts again why would they say that
Alex about that that Alex Smith is
better than Kirk Cousins well we have a
lot of people tweeting at us during
Monday Night Football and being like ooh
did you hear what Booker just said I
wonder who which coach told him that
exactly right so when all three
announcers go off on Josh no norman's no
longer the second there the best corner
on the team that's not just like they
Joe testator stumbled on this in his
film study and was like hey guys you
know what I think we should talk about
no book yeah this I thought that was
pretty good
hey book
hey book you got a lot of jewelry on
that hand down there got to get excited
we got a real Super Bowl winner down
there a book mcFarland good to have you
on the broadcast now let's go to Lisa
Salters who little ravioli yeah a little
more bass to your voice you're close hey
hey book
what's up book but yes good job wit that
was being something that I'm sure was
fed to them through talking to the
coaches oh me oh they're the most
transparent they are like I'll just be
like the coach just told was talking to
junior and he's not been impressed with
the secondary coaches said all right
just to kind of show like look we've
been talking a lot of East Coast teams
there is an East Coast bias New Orleans
is not on the East Coast's we're talk
about Washington and Washington but
there are advantages to East Coast
biased if you're not on the East Coast
if you want to get attention for good
plays playing in New York in New England
yeah with the with either of the New
York teams Philadelphia it helps you it
does but if you're doing things that are
wrong maybe it's good for you Odell
makes a comment that his quarterback
can't run anymore and people thought
that he called out his entire lifetime
existence as negligible Antonio Brown as
we have aforementioned has threatened to
break a reporter's jaw has recorded a
Facebook live in the locker room has had
multiple tantrums on the sidelines
openly yelling at coaches other players
and knocking off Gatorades
and now is being sued for throwing items
off a balcony and nearly hitting a
two-year-old child throwing tens of
thousands of dollars of expenses vaz
--is but guess what when I turn on FL
live today they're breaking down Lil
Wayne again there is an advantage if
you're not on the East Coast and you get
in trouble mm-hm and tawny o Brown does
not have to worry about being more
famous but I'll tell you what he also
doesn't have to worry about getting
called out in the media it really is
incredible to watch I mean O'Dell if he
was doing this he's getting roasted he's
getting destroyed he's getting cut he's
good cut they're gonna be like damn they
don't we can't deal with you anymore and
you can't say that Antonio Brown doesn't
play for a less moral franchise because
the Rooney
are right up there with the Maris yeah
it's just interesting there's one I'm
just gonna keep reminding people again
and again we're not hating an Antonio
Brown hating I'm just presenting facts
it's just it is amazing the double
standard and it's with all across the
board right now and anything with
football just whatever it is comparing
who's better it's really crazy because
it's not like Antonio Brown doesn't have
crazy hair and like a super huge like
social media following like he really is
the Odell of Pittsburgh but they're just
covered completely different and the
theory is with East Coast bias when good
morning football based in New York Pro
Football Talk based in Connecticut NBC
all of the producers not even just the
talent don't always play in the talent
yeah when they pick up their New York
Post right and they pick up their New
York Daily News
and the front page is Odell
subconsciously that's the top story in
there it's a problem yeah I listen in
every newsroom that's the sports
newsroom around the country the biggest
problem is most of the people in those
newsrooms are from New York or Boston
that's why I read the Pittsburgh
post-gazette every morning that for you
that anything I do
that is totally that's you though it
really is I can huge fan of the the
Louisiana Times Picayune oh that what do
you read Sims Vegas Journal review
another great they were nice I'm a big
Sacramento Bee guy what do you got Sims
name a paper
the Dallas Morning is nice yes an
American Statesman Philadelphia Inquirer
ooh never heard of it really yeah I
really don't want to sound like a drew
brees hater hater though like I have an
ultimate respect for him I'm just trying
to I don't want I don't want people to
think I'm a hater on that yes that
bothers me if you just said that drew
Brees is fighting to be the ninth best
quarterback of all time yeah it's just
funny because if they see 10 and you're
at the bottom of that list it's bad but
there's thousands of other quarterbacks
that come after 9 yeah thousands I know
but you know a Terry Bradshaw is the
most interesting one you said because
you see the rings and you're thinking
when he does important for that one I
don't know what that show does that so
many winning doesn't matter for some
guys and then other ones it gets used
for and
that's it annoys the other conversation
right now in Pittsburgh we're gonna put
Sims right now on fantasy watch Big Ben
comes out and he wants James Conner to
still get carries once levian returns
quote I will push for James to get as
much run as we can because we've seen
some great things from him in all phases
of football he picks up blitz is he
catching the ball he's running hard he's
making plays he's playing with passion
so we need to keep using that Sims
there's a lot of guys out there on their
fantasy teams they got James Connor
some people have levy on bail some
people have both some people might be
trading for one what's your read on when
James Connor gets back what happens in
that backfield
well people you can go both ways it's an
option this day and age it's 2018 so if
you want to go both ways running backs
starting in the backs or spectrum it's
all good I find that it be an
interesting quote very because it's big
I guess this outpost is big been saying
this to actually help the levee on bail
situation like hey Le'Veon you don't
have to come we won't we won't abuse you
right away when you get in cuz we know
those women's issues I'm just throwing
out food for thought I'm talking I don't
I don't know where I really so is he
saying it that way to also go like you
know let's let's make levian feel like
we're not gonna just abuse him when he
gets back and go hey first game back
here's 40 touches kill yourself left
comedia never forget that someone's
asking in this question yes what do you
thinks could happen to James Connor when
levian gets back he cannot answer we go
full levy on yeah like James Connor I
know you got a run against Cincinnati
right but like by the way in two weeks
after goodbye we can't say though I know
you're exactly right so you have to take
that into account other thing I would
say just other food for thought is maybe
he's saying that cuz he's trying to
remember mine the team last year that
when Le'Veon Bell wasn't there for
training camp he was not very good to
the first two or three games of the
season and he realized hey let's not put
all that pressure on loving a bell that
I'm letting into shape that's just the
things and I'm just gonna add this for
food to thought for everybody I traded
food for thought what did I say who to
thought I don't think
I traded James Conner in one of my
leagues and the reason I waited till
after the Falcons game yeah is don't
evaluate James Conner I guess Falcons
against against Christian McCaffrey
Christian McCaffrey had 14 catches a
hundred and two yards against the Saints
their running backs had 18 catches for a
hundred and thirty-one yards against the
Steelers four catches 75 against the
Bengals six for 55 and freakin Giovanni
Bernard had two rushing touchdowns the
Eagles had two rushing touchdowns in the
two games that so in two games they
allowed 32 catches two McCaffrey and
Kamara in the other three games they
allowed six rushing touchdowns so that's
why let's not get too high James Conner
just the Falcons defense versus running
backs is the ultimate fan do play this
segment brought to you by fan dude is
Atlanta have this week
Tampa Bay oh you better scoop up Peyton
Barbour know you might scoop up Ronald
Jones you might do pop Jacquizz Rodgers
might scoop of them and they just go
ahead and have you seen the secondary
they're so horrible forget our running
game we're gonna throw all I know is I
trip I trade it for Mike Evans and I'm
very excited you should be Jameis
Winston and his best friend Mike Evans
against Atlanta here left goes made a
few fantasy trade oh yeah he's making
moves around the office every
salesperson metal listen my I made Jerry
Jones over here I will say this though
my friend that's the Commissioner is not
responding to me he's not your friend
two three days and why is he bothered
that you're making me made the trades
and he said I'm gonna veto one of these
because I don't think it's fair and I
said are you kidding a judge well he's
he makes a lot of crazy trades and I
said if you veto that trade I'm not in
the league next year that's an abuse of
power you're hypocritical and now he
hasn't texted me back I sent him a
picture of us when we were two and I was
like yo man I was like you a skill to an
all-time level right gonna get a
response not responded wait okay Evan
Washu I miss you miss you too Evan
because he thinks I took advantage of
people why the [ __ ] is he the Commish
for one cuz he's the commissioner holds
a debt he's he's the most Gattaca but
like if a guy wants to make a trade like
are we air peep
throwing games in the fan character you
can veto and fantasy right if let's say
I trade you James Conner for Odell and
you didn't know that levy on bells
getting back and like I took advantage
or I told you something that wasn't true
if my team sucks and your team is good
and there's a thousand bucks to be had I
could just trade you my players you give
a money's in you can give a money and
then you give me a cut got you yeah but
I have receipts in which these people
actually offered me the trade so I was
like all I did was accept right so I
don't know but I might lose a friendship
that's fantasy football man don't be so
sensitive Ryan Evan Evan Evan I just I
need your friendship back I love you
don't be so sensitive Evan um what's
happens last name I'm not I'm not giving
that that much one other question though
about the coach and the player thing why
do we say that Jared Goff is a product
of McVeigh and not girly okay um I mean
we're not coming from this is a question
on Twitter I'll pull up oh it is yeah I
I get that I mean yeah girly is a
product of McVeigh to a degree yeah he
gets the ball with a lot but but the
point is is that this is from Chris
Thomas right I mean yeah hey his I
wonder if it's Chris Thomas that I know
the generic name but the point the point
is listen the coarse McVeigh any
offensive good player it has is helped
out by his coach for the most part okay
the big thing is again what he does with
those opportunities right and like Todd
Gurley would have walked in the end zone
with Mark Ingram screen catch that he
got tackled at the - Todd Gurley would
have walked in if it was back another 50
yards he would have walked in for a
touchdown so he maximizes and does more
outside the scope there's also times
when yeah okay Todd Gurley catches the
screen and I go oh that's a great
reception great job by McVeigh get in
the ball but then he gets into the
corner of the field here and there's
three people around him and he breaks
somebody's ankles and now it runs four
people back to the middle of the field
and I go well though that's not Sean
McVeigh McVeigh wasn't out there making
a block for him
or doing so it's it's I I get it those
are hard things to balance but again you
have to go what was there to be had what
did the guy do with his physical ability
to make more than what was there to be
had like I'm watching Rams highlights on
Sunday night and the guy is every
highlight going golf goes to a wide open
Woods golf throws to a wide open cup and
then they get done with a segment they
go man golf was really on his game
wasn't he and I just it's not that I'm
mad at golf but I just go what you just
described how open the receivers were
every time yes and now we're gonna act
like he was the difference in the game
he made it was awesome I'm not trying it
but that happens all the time Brady was
the same thing on Thursday night yes
Brady's come out with laser-like
precision he is laser-focused or this
one whoa all those three yard and behind
the line of scrimmage passes again I'm
not taking it away from him he's doing
what he's supposed he is and but don't
compare that to third and and whatever
repaired when the homes hit Sherman and
there's a guy draped all over it I got a
statistic for you ninety-five point
seven percent since 2016 yeah the QB
sneak on fourth and one is 67 of seventy
right 95.7% why doesn't everyone just go
for it on fourth and one wwbd
what would Belichick do the exact oh oh
wait he's been sneaking for the last 15
years Tom Brady sneaks probably more
than any a hundred percent I don't know
the stats of that I will bet $1,000 to
anybody out there that comes away and
goes oh no this quarterback has actually
sneaked it more than Tom Brady over the
last 10 years I just don't think it
exists and I don't even know that for a
fact but I'm not confident in my ability
to watch football and realize that so
this is making me think about play
calling because I'm thinking about Jason
Garrett and yanking about young play
callers and we can ask this a lot
sometimes we make a lot about the
McVeigh's and the Kyle Shanahan's and
McDaniels and the Sean Payton's and the
brainiacs that are on offense why do you
think we're not seeing that on the
defensive side or are we are there
young and up-and-coming defensive minds
that are in the sport right now that
could be that guy why do I feel like I'm
getting more innovation offensively than
defensively and I'm not talking about
because the rules are favoring offense
yeah which we all know they are well
that's helping the situation out yes
right I mean it's helping it out
certainly I mean they're you're allowed
to do things and the you know wide
receiver screens and all that stuff that
wasn't part of the game but like we said
we saw the Seattle scheme Zimmer's
double a gap threatens and all that
stuff we've talked about uber flus
before and what he could possibly be but
do you think that people just naturally
when they become that into football want
to be on the offensive side of the ball
more times than not I think is it you're
defensive you get more of the creative
guys that go I'd rather be on the
offensive side of the ball those guys
that are like you know and then you get
more of your for lack of a better phrase
like militaristic discipline guys
they're the defensive coaches we're like
no this is your gap do your job and the
offensive coach is like man if I had
just told that guy to run this route
during last week next week I'm gonna
change that play and instead of running
the post he's gonna run the post corner
yeah like so I think you get a different
that other thing is I mean offensively
right now the passers and catchers are
better than ever before I mean just for
all the things we've talked about it's
it's football's been the most popular
sport for 30 years running in the NFL at
least and I think you're getting your
best athletes going I want to play
receiver a quarterback and that's why we
see freaks of nature like Odell Beckham
jr. and AJ green and Julio and Antonio
and all that yeah but I mean I feel you
I do think there's more innovation on
the offenses out of the ball right now
or do you think that innovation on the
offensive side of the ball is it's
punctuated by a touchdown like when you
see a touchdown you go that was creative
whereas defense it might end up in a
deflection or it might end up in a
tackle for a loss or a sack and we don't
always see it right I don't know yeah I
don't know weed there um
I look for on defense you're gonna let
up yards I look up for people doing
things outside the box thinking in
critical situations or
like you feel that way about Sean
McTernan like when I went through your
notes on Buffalo you're like man they
always are in the right spot and they're
diagnosing it is it because it's a chess
match where the offense goes first and
the defense has to react or predict yes
there's the offense is more like here's
my new creation well the defense is like
I figured you out
the defense is always worried about
what's going to screw me is this sound
that's that has to be your thought
because you can't go while this is
really creative but if they throw it
back to the Lakers off the left side
that's awesome and I'm gonna sack them
for 20-yard gain but oh gosh if they run
the ball to the left we might not touch
him when he runs for a touchdown do you
think we'll see a scheme like another 46
defense something that were like another
cover three press bail like history says
that the next time you're a new
defensive scheme will come around yes
that's good like Rex Ryan had a seven
year no doubt about it Rex Ryan Seattle
you know I think all that Pittsburgh had
that going for a little while we can't
take blitz right I mean yeah I do think
we'll see something I don't know if it's
there right now you know Wade Phillips
has some things where I look at and go
it's really cool what he does as far as
game planning little things he does on a
weekly basis but but it's also relying
on town I don't know I don't yeah I
don't know if there is that next genius
right there on the defensive side of the
ball but it will happen here in the next
few years I do believe that we're gonna
see another shift in how teams play
defensive football and I really think
it's gonna end up going to what I told
you it's gonna go to let's get the
biggest people possible up front and
then just have really fast seven guys in
the background back so we could against
the run and we got free Catholics on the
backend for all the screens pick plays
passes all that and honestly I think
that's what Wade Phillips is already
doing I think he started that trend he's
got two corners playing safety right now
he's got three corners playing safety
really between Roby nickel nickel Roby
Coleman Joyner our man Joe Johnson or
John Johnson who's kind of a corner
slash safety okay then he plays three
defensive tackles on the field every
just about its sudhana lawful we're kind
of doing that this we all do right I
think that's the next thing and I think
New England's kind of been doing it they
just don't know why they traded Danny
Shelton Danny Shelton Malcolm Brown lays
bare front more than New England with
big people nobody because they just go
okay we're gonna put three big guys
could do it the Jets could do it so yeah
it'll be it'll be something soon but
it's not there right now to where I can
give you one guy and go ooh this is the
next big thing
my other theory about why offensive
wonder kin comes and defensive guys are
not is I think when you're trying to
innovate it's good to have a fresh
perspective so you could be a little bit
more rebellious when you're young
because you're not ingrained in anything
yeah Sean McVeigh when he's been a coach
for 15 years is gonna get stale
eventually unless he's able to
constantly create and keep an atmosphere
where originality is improved right but
defense the Fangio's the dean pieces the
Lobos there's something about having
seen everything that it allows you to
prepare yeah where is since you're more
reacting to offenses having an inventory
of all possible sets of things you can
harken back to that like Belichick
Belichick has seen everything so
nothing's new so maybe that's why we
don't see any young guys on defense
because they're gonna they're gonna go
I'm gonna bring that five-person blitz
and then the Dean P sits back and goes
you know where you're vulnerable yeah
exactly right you know I think that's
why I think that happened to McDermott
McDermott was running to Jim Johnson all
these creative blitzes and it fell apart
because also yeah it fell apart because
offenses started to go wait like that
are leaving yourself that's tough but
yes being we've messed up forget doing
this we should just run this play over
here and they're gonna they can't defend
it yeah and that's what happened then he
had to go to the drawing board and he
meets up with Ron Rivera who was a
different scheme and thought process and
he goes damn okay let me show someone
what he's got so like I know we call him
riverboat Ron but he's very concerned
very concerned
let's call big Phil [ __ ] big Phil
[ __ ] how do you come a week since I'm
talking to him he's doing mentally right
now he's doing good two days a week he's
fine it's been very active on Twitter
the last two days
really a lot of retweeting Wow some
videos of him talking about the Browns
oh well
probably not but yeah who is doing the
tweeting for him hello hello the hell's
going on I'm talk to you guys forever
Wow who's gonna you've been tweeting a
lot I'm being told here at the BR
offices when I get a chance are you
doing it Phil yes I do it said to you
you two helping a lot of stuff that I
say on TV and all that stuff you're
doing a good job you're all over the
place really am i killing anybody my
taking prisoners winner well sure yeah
you're doing a great job he was wild
Phil wild
yeah really oh good that's right I'm a
wild guy so you know I've talked to you
guys in a while and I got to tell you I
really mean this I didn't miss you
not a bit not a second not even a damns
I do watch your show on Wednesdays night
Wednesday nights and you know I sit
there to my wife and we watch it and
Adam you do a great job and and I go are
you sure that's our son honey are you
sure did you fool around to something
going on here why what about Chris's
performance makes you say that
no nothing I'm just being a jerk Adam
remiss up bro go with your strength and
life okay what are you saying I'm just
saying you know I like to be that guy so
that I'm just being who I want to be
right here that's okay big ball buster
three brothers that beat my ass for many
years so I'm just that dude I'm a little
like okay
permanently read a sweet film what
Christopher said it right I got
permanent red ass what what sibling
number were you age wise I was the fifth
down fifth of five centimeter at debate
this is incredible
so I'm reading this I had three older
brothers and let's say my oldest brother
was really mean to me
Dominic so Phil so Phil not not to get
too crazy I'm reading this book called
originals by Adam grant I'm in this
chapter right now where they're talking
about birth order and they've realized
that the the top like four base dealers
of all
all had like four older siblings and
there's this there's this correlation
they're finding between people that are
lower in birth order and they're willing
to take more risks you obviously have to
speak louder because there was a lot
more people you're more rebellious
because the older siblings be take on
the parenting to the younger siblings
but no but they enforce they enforce
their own rules I mean yeah that's a
good point yes yes it's a we had to live
by their about what they wanted yes and
so I find it very fitting and then I
look at your sons I think about Chris
and Matt and then I think about me and
my brother Jason and the younger one is
always the more rebellious one and it's
because the older one helps set the laws
it's just you being a fifth of eight is
like to a tee for this book it's perfect
oh that's funny good stuff there we go
so you're educating me I need try and
feed a little I'll be the one of the
three of us that reads a book so what do
you mean I read books all the time play
books no I read health books usually you
know trying to figure out how to feel
better read I read all this and
Christopher knows it I read books and
underlying it today and then I say hey
I'll give it to you but I you know I
underlying all the key parts that I
wanted to read but he still wouldn't
read it if I gave it to him I don't know
if I'm given any that I've underlined
but we should do a say yeah you gave me
the one like back books that you
underlined a bunch of yeah I did I gave
it I gave it a just a little skin a
little skin like a because I was like
you on the way to the gym one day let me
just look at some of the exercises that
could help my back here real quick okay
throw it in the garbage okay so what's
going on what what can you hey you know
I just want what do you want to talk
about go ahead yeah why I watch the
Eagles play the Minnesota Vikings and
behind in my schedule some a little you
know I don't like getting behind yeah
your whole family's like that yeah no
kidding we're all I'm just ironic that
way usually like my Wednesday I'm or
whatever but you guys have 22 weeks of
freaking out about not being able to
watch film like for 22 weeks you guys
are like I got like seven more games to
watch it seven more
because you never know when that
question is going to come up when it
comes my way brother I'm gonna smack it
out the door you know what I'm saying
yeah you just never know and what you
see in the film
Eagles Vikings Eagles Vikings Kirk
Cousins every game that I've watched
this year think about the RAM game
there's one exception of course an apple
on a soda
but in Buffalo so does make an all
quarterback Minnesota in Buffalo yes Bob
Lowe's make it all quarterbacks look
pretty average right I mean you know
one's thrown over 300 yet against them
all I believe it I mean if they cover
well their concepts everything they do
but Kirk Cousins throwing under pressure
man hit right and he is not afraid he is
not checked down charlie he has rip it
down the field and you go oh I was good
throw well I was really good throw
that's all you do the whole time you
watch him and I know it wasn't good
enough for Washington but if he wasn't
in Minnesota I don't know where they'd
be yeah I mean that we're gonna be these
upgrade over Case Keenum identify that a
doubt well of course yes yes III just I
I said that the Christopher and you guys
probably last year man he's just has
gotten better as a thrower it seems like
every year and now maybe it's the dome
playing indoors or one playing indoors
out in Los Angeles now neither in Green
Bay or last week yeah no he just stripe
in that [ __ ] I think you're right but
yeah that's the word to say that's what
I was looking for son thing yeah no
problem I know I mean it's good but you
know it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
they gotta win the Super Bowl or we're
gonna all of us morons they keep saying
Kirk Cousins is no good we can keep
saying it because he didn't win the
Super Bowl and you know all the morons
I'm talking about yes yeah yeah yeah
it's great because you know how I know
Kirk Cousins good because I watched Alex
Smith on Monday you know like how
different is that Washington team but
you know you cannot run the same offense
for both of them Phil we just had a
conversation and I'm gonna cut you off
because I think this is exciting
Chris said that he he's not a hater of
Drew Brees he just has a hard time
putting him ahead of eight other
quarterback
all time yeah I mean I said he's in the
conversation for the top ten you know I
never will he be in the top five for me
I don't care if he wins another Super
Bowl and throws for ten thousand more
yards but I just said you know he's in
that conversation of somewhere between
nine and twelve nine and thirteen for me
with the Bradshaw Warren Moon I said
he'll never pass these eight guys for me
like hands down Rodgers I mean Rodgers
Elway Brady Peyton Moreno Favre Montana
Bradshaw those eight right there and
then we threw in the warm moons and
Stahl back who I know you think so
highly of and I do then yeah Roger
Staubach would be like the ultimate
quarterback in today's game oh my gosh
right I didn't realize I'd be get to
play against him one cut two times which
was really cool but I never realized
until I'd look at games now and just go
man Roger the Dodger was really the
Dodger I'm he was really run and move he
was like Aaron Rodgers yeah and of
course he had a big wind-up to throw he
threw the ball like a baseball but he
had a strong arm and you know toughest
all could be and just I just didn't
realize what a good runner and I think
about that all the time you know you got
to be careful about these numbers
they're they're going off the charts and
it's going to continue it's only going
to stay where it is or get bigger yeah
but I've talked to some of these guys
that Christopher's talking about and you
know and I don't ask them but I say
things they go oh my god I mean what I
like to play today and yeah I mean come
on Dan Marino John Elway what would they
be doing in today's game right
what would a healthy Dan Marino do he
would throw for 6,000 yards every game
but people forget do what he cares but
when he was younger and he stayed before
he got hurt he could let it go with
anybody right and he was dead i dick man
he didn't miss yeah so I know you got it
you got to judge it that way and and
Drew Brees it's unbelievable what he's
done and and and and I noticed it when I
interviewing lastly first off is truly
like humble and one of the greatest guys
you ever meet right but to overcome the
fact that nobody warned him that you
know out there in San Diego all I did
was go the Pro Bowl you know and all
that but whatever they draft Phillip
Rivers that worked out and he's got a
call thank god those doctors in Miami
wouldn't give me the okay because I
would got to come down to New Orleans
with Sean Payton right he would have
been he would have been Manning with
Nick Saban who knows my change Nick
Saban's life - he might have snacks
tournament but it probably chased Nick
Saban where he wanted to go is okay if I
can't make decisions why the hell about
a head coach right so there you go it's
worked out pretty well for both but just
like everything just like Tom Brady and
Josh McDaniels Drew Brees found himself
in a coach and that is Sean Payton and
that has a huge deal with how much
success you have in today's game in
today's game more than ever
so yeah last thing I got a question
there Adam knows I love your perspective
Eagles Giants Thursday night my
Philadelphia Eagles you and
Christopher's New York Giants right
you're gonna enjoy on the Wednesday show
me and Sims me and Chris went back and
forth on Eagles Giants fandom how
special is this robbery man
well it's pretty good and I know I know
you think that Odell kind of clear the
air for the Giants I know you agree with
me there I really do I mean I think okay
now we can get over all this stuff and
then at least for a week or two or you
know at least for tomorrow night
I think it galvanizes the team I really
do
and maybe it eases Odell's mine too also
and he's got to realize you know it's
kind of like we saw it building didn't
we just little bit with Odell and you
know look in interviews and all that
sometimes I did it myself I'd wake up
and go oh my god I'm in the back page of
the paper yeah and I didn't know I was
really saying that or whatever but I
said it and it when you read in print
you go
hi I'm such an idiot and
but and that happens to all players and
so not that I'm giving Odell a pass
but it was a great lesson learned uh
don't trust anybody what do I say to
rookie quarterbacks don't listen to the
radio don't read the papers brother you
know you'll be a lot better off so what
I do I said it and I do believe it's
going to help the Giants and you think
the Giants have their best game of the
year Thursday I saw I do I know in the
game if the Giants don't throw the ball
well against this Eagles secondary and
then I thought they would really they
had a good day throwing the ball against
Carolina or just okay but I thought it
was going to be much better I just
thought that the way the Carolina
Panthers play was really gonna help you
know the Giants pass he game and you
know the Eagles that when they play
man-to-man I'm watching Minnesota go up
and down the field I'm just thinking man
Odell in Turley Sheppard they can do
this to Phil Phil you get up to the line
you look left you look right and Jalen
Mills is one-on-one - Odell what's going
on in your head well I'm gonna think
about what I'm gonna do and celebrate
when after a touchdown you know double
move city you can't they just can't put
themselves in that type of situations
you don't have to do that though don't
they they do they do and you know to the
okay so that's great now what are you
gonna do okay let's put all this
coverage back there and you know I keep
saying it say qualms Berkeley he's gonna
have two games this year where he is
this gonna win the game by himself I do
believe that he's gonna have that 175
yard game and it's it's gonna be it's
gonna win the game for me just go
they're gonna dominate I do see that
game coming you think I can you think
they're gonna the game like as far as
running the ball like they're gonna
dominate that way you think that's gonna
happen this week I think you want it you
know throw just throwing the football
yes but running the football I would
hope that or I'm sure the Eagles are
going if you want to run it make a
living out of that hey Phil Phil it's
coming next Monday night
is Falcon's October 22nd could be their
sake 1 250 yards they don't have a
selection anxiety against the Falcons
whether the other game the other game
will do B two days before Christmas
Giants Colts that will be the other game
it happens Colts are starting to get a
little know but the bike yeah the
Atlanta you don't know what to do you
don't know where to throw it or run it
because you just go wild this is really
what do we do this is our gonna work and
maybe you we've run it a little more to
slow the game down because our deep
whatever but a llantas defense man
alright here's the last thing last thing
last thing I just want to know what you
think god this is because of course the
big game of the week is Chiefs Patriots
right turn hatred yes everybody thinks
this is this is the thing I keep getting
around and I don't know if you saw me
this morning but everyone is all I mean
the Patriots are probably you know run
the ball Tony Michelle Chris sits on the
pregame show they're gonna they're gonna
keep mahomes off the field that way and
my and I think dad you would agree and
we haven't talked about this but my two
cents was with every big game New
England's been in in the last five years
yep there's been a few times where we've
thought that same thing and they come
out and go empty shotgun put it in
Brady's hands and [ __ ] running the ball
and we'll throw 50 million 5 yard passes
and then hit you're on behind you it
right so don't you think that's gonna
happen well it's not quite exactly how I
would have phrased it but you're right I
just I just don't think the Patriots are
ready to make that change of like oh
we're gonna run the ball
ground-and-pound they're not that no
they don't want to shorten a game in a
situation like this is the answer right
I shorten the game when you know their
defense is not good exactly prolong it
give ourselves more opportunities
opportunities with NASA's plays and time
and they will win the war yeah their
defense is better than Kansas City now I
will say this I don't know what happened
but d4 decided to become one pick I know
and I'm going to play he looks like and
I'm thinking damn is that d4 Von Miller
yeah and it really is it's really
amazing what did he do where the light
finally came on the truck here no well
that well it actually is because he's
dead uncle well and he's been hurt the
first three years of his career I mean
it's it's been constant so he's at knee
hip ankle I mean lower VI feels a lot
like Brandon Graham for the Eagles where
you had three four years of yeah and
then all of a sudden it clicks yeah I
understand you know and I will say this
Kansas City is you know they got a few
pieces on their defense you know I do
like you know like Chris Jones I've
liked him and Who am I missing upfront
well honey Lamar Houston's there elimar
but one of the big guys the other big
Allen Bailey you probably think of
Bailey yeah I mean so they've got
something there but hey New England
they're gonna make you cover everything
ran backers and you know is Reggie
Ragland gonna cover somebody man demand
and definitely not in there absolutely
not
I hey I picked New England I feel really
strong about it I just don't see him
losing this game yeah I hear you you the
man felt what I bet any money I don't
like you to how you two guys doing in
your bed no money no y'all should put up
your own money for real then I'll watch
you and really take something into close
I would be losing so I don't want to do
that
I went ten and four against the spread
last week Phil that is incredible I
can't go I can't he might break even
just picking winners yes you know
sometimes now it's gotten to where
picking winners I think is harder than
picking this bread it's just because
every game is so close whatever happens
but no I'm giving you a good suggestion
for your show more people will tune in
if you bend your own money I mean damn
you're both making tons of money let's
go great advice villain I'll get I'll
get them to put up Adams money next week
on the show don't worry I mean come on
but I come on that show we're gonna bet
real money
you know what's mild and sloppy get
fired Phil that random segment where I
have random people bet money if you have
a bet if you've bet within this year
you'd be up about $900 oh that would be
nine hundred my betting every week
there's 50
50 bucks none FS 250 a week Oh 250 yes
that's what I thought okay you'd be up
like 900 dollars right now oh cool you
know you know what you know how much
money I need right more where that's it
brother you finally get your kitchen on
I need more let's go brother good day
hey man see you dad
all right from our old quarterback to
the young quarterback he's a brother did
he become Hulk Hogan over the weekend or
that or he's working for house you
saying it at the end yeah okay brother
all right from our old quarterback to
young quarterback Sims Dovan to the
notebook and I had him watch all the
young quarterbacks you heard what he had
to say about Baker Mayfield saying that
Baker Mayfield is the dude he stripes it
all that stuff yeah let's go to the
third pick in the draft
Sam darn old you watched the film Jets
offense Denver defense I'm gonna go
through your nose yeah darn 'old throw
in the ball well early his feet and legs
are in throws ball is better quality
that deep bomb to Robby Anderson well as
Roby peeked in the backfield thought it
was a blitz you cannot do that
another great bomb to Robbie darn 'old
all about his feet you wrote this was
his best game throwing the ball yeah and
you mentioned multiple times his feet is
that the difference and where are you
right now with Sam yeah I think that's
part of it I mean hey listen there's
things that we're still in the
evaluation process of Sam but I still
think overall it's it's still very good
from what we're seeing just as a total
work of art but yeah there's been I
would say moments and the Cleveland game
few Thursday's ago and then last week in
Jacksonville where he gets into what he
did at USC last year where okay he wants
to throw the ball to 12 o'clock but his
feet are at nine and three well that's
just that's not gonna work yeah you know
yeah you might get away with that
against Washington State and stuff like
that and and you know but in the NFL the
room for error error is just so much
smaller so when you see a guy yeah go
from a game where he didn't have good
fundamentals right to a game that he did
yeah does that make you go okay he
clearly watched the tape and he worked
on right does that give you a lot of
hope that that
can be the new norm and yes I think that
it shows me at least that they know that
that's an issue with them and that
they're gonna continue to stay on that
and G recognizes that so if he would
have thrown two deep balls to Robbie
right his feet were at nine and three
he'll throw it to noon you'd still go I
know he hit that but his feet are an
issue yeah I would go yeah I would I
would sir you always a great throw but I
wasn't wowed like see I don't give a
damn about the stats he was ten of
twenty-two and I would bet you on five
of those incompletions the ball off his
hand I said there you go Sam there you
go that looks the way it's supposed to
look for another foam quarterback back
leg underneath them hitch and into it
shoulder and front leg
you know just slightly right of the
targets great like that's why it has to
be and when he does that he never loses
the ball for you know like some of his
incompletions in the game this week a
key through them where he wanted to he
was being safe it was a deep out route
let me just be saving throwing high up
you know it was a few out routes that
were really impressive I don't know I
know because he had he had a base
underneath them again it's the big thing
I mean you're a little excited I could
tell I love cuz I want to root for Sam
so hard right guy and I like seeing when
guys go yeah I haven't been as good as I
can be the last two weeks and I don't
have to wait til after the season to
correct these things I can do them right
now and that's cool to see especially at
a young guy I text him after the game I
said a way to kick ass today and he
responded yeah you know that is no
California it's like a surfer type of
thing you just yell each other it's ye W
yo yeah I got this wave yeah you know I
remember I I went to apartment emoji or
it's just ye w he did the UI aw and I
sent back this emoji gotcha I remember I
was at a party in California there's a
lot of stuff going on and I remember I
went back for this after party just I
don't want to get into it and I went to
this after party and we go to this
girl's place and there's like a bunch of
us and on her wall had ye W and
Christmas lights and I was like what is
that and everyone is like yo yo yo and I
was like what the hell I've had my
bedroom she also had surfboards on her
wall and she had a little jar and I said
what's that jar and she was Australian
and she goes it's my safe JA
every day I do ants if I put a dollar in
the jaw and I was like she goes makes me
want to surf more and I was like that's
amazing yeah wait that's amazing she had
a pole in her apartment all right next
one a pole yeah yeah for core strength
this person gets better and better she
was making yes Josh Allen Buffalo
offense to ever D by the way let me just
also say this the Jets offense Denver D
you wrote multiple times men you don't
rush for 300 by luck this was a double
whammy this was a physical ass-whooping
and a schematic alas well thank you you
wrote that the Jets beat that crap out
of the Broncos and the only reason it
was closed was because Denver got all
their stats when it was already 27 it
today they just kicked their ass again
it's a farce this would be again at
garbage time stats that I would bet you
that Denver had 200 yards total when the
game was competitive and meant something
their last two drives the game down what
was a twenty seven ten they put together
I mean I think Case Keenum threw for
like 220 yards in the fourth quarter
defensively you said Leonard William
Avery Williamson and Jamaal Adams every
week pops Avery Williamson and Jamaal
Adams they diagnose a play and they
really make a move yeah the issue at
Denver and we talked about it with velde
or being out Billy Turner you wrote
Billy Turner and McGovern 12 it's alive
and got their ass whupped a lot a lot
yeah but you did say Phillip Lindsey
especially Phillip Lindsey was one
broken tackle away multiple times from
having the day Isaiah Crowell did write
again there's a guy that would be an
example again a guy that does more than
what's given like you said yeah he
almost broke the tackle but he made like
four moves before that yes you're
absolutely right so that's doing more
than what's there to be how Oh timeout
I'm gonna need $20 and I'm gonna need my
$20 back we'll do it tomorrow I'll do
tomorrow just know that it's KTM
actually I'm low on cash I hit all your
important notes okay the run game thing
was amazing though Oh Isiah Crowell they
Jeremy Bates crack the code like I love
Lausanne Broncos run Fitz and exposed it
yes I mean first is you can't have do
you want to tell him something are you
no he's gonna tell me that I need to
hurry up the first thing is what debt
what he did to that more than anything
is you can't have a linebacker
responsible for covering the tight end
man-to-man and then also have him
respond so over the B gap in the run
game so what Jeremy based it on some of
the runs was goes I'm just gonna tie
downs not even gonna block I'm gonna
have him run out to the flat like he's
running around the blind backer ball him
then there's nobody there for the B guy
and then I say a crawl goes 75 up the
middle BAM
it was a number of instances like that
so when you see that what is your
opinion of the offensive coordinator
what happens then I just go oh he's
found something through evaluating all
week and watching film what kind of
respect to you then get for a guy like
chair well I have a lot of respect for
Jeremy anyways but yeah it just makes me
look at him and go ah man I mean Jeremy
he understands defenses he understood
what bands Joseph was trying to do as a
game play other side of the ball games
Joseph he sees this huge issue yes does
he just do they go think I tried to fix
it finally they finally started getting
these formations they were like alright
we're gonna have to fix a plays own or
will please play man with the corners
and the three linebackers will play like
funnel where they just funnel to to the
three guys to each other something like
that but yes I mean at first I don't
know if he realized the disappointing
thing about the Denver is they don't set
the edge in the run game I don't even
understand it I mean they got guys like
Bradley Chubb ooh it's crashed down in
everybody got wedged in there crow well
or powell bounced outside and there's
nobody there except for bad tackling
corners oh you mean the 220 pound freak
running back can make the corner miss
who doesn't really want to tackle
anyways shocker so that's bull shame on
you for putting that corner there when
you know that's not his strength but
then yes things like that or you know
it's a 2 by 2 set and the inside
receiver from the left motions to the
right and now it's a three by one set
the linebackers have kicked over the
safeties now are going back to rotate
and nobody's back in the backside B gap
and you just go and you wonder why you
let up 300 yards rushing like those are
little things that he's going to have to
fix next week he's probably been
cheating them if I went back now and
watched where he's been cheating these
kind of things like how I said defense
is always worried about I gotta be sound
I gotta have all gallon saket he
- cheated these on a few games and just
been like I'm gonna just see if I can
get away with it
and he did and he did but Jeremy you
noticed it and said you can't do this
there's always it's our good offensive
coordinator goes it's our job to point
out there flaws that show them they
can't do that
who is that crude you said I think it's
our duty to show them that this blitz is
unsound and we have to gas them for it
that's like a very like military movie
like it's very much it's our duty men to
beat them into submission
Josh Allen another rookie quarterback
they got a win taking on Tennessee great
call off go thanks bro
seriously those are both great cause bro
Jets
well the Jets one is I look for those I
know you do I look for the West Coast
vehicle thanks bro Josh Allen a lot of
your comments about him were the lack of
support yeah you wrote there's no town
around Allen is this the worst wide
receivers in the NFL it ends that
offensive lines bad too then you wrote
Buffalo's wide receivers slowest least
twitchy bunch I have seen in a while and
that leads to ints Allen throwing on run
needs improvement not quality balls he
got to do a little bit of like what we
saw and what we heard about him in
Wyoming and things like that just some
of them aren't they were complete but he
can throw better quite against or
incompletion I'm about the quality of
the look I know the completions are
gonna come these are NFL quarterbacks
either way I'm not worried about that
it's the look it's the quality yes and
there was a few that I was just like
come on man like don't revert back to
this like Wyoming independent arm
contractor thing on the run when he had
worked so hard to fix it and has made so
many good throws on the run early in the
year not concerned about it but I just
felt like a crapped creek creep back in
and then really that's a serious
conversation about the receivers like
the worst wide receiver core you've seen
yeah I mean I'm just I'm opening up the
floor to you guys there I mean do you
know who else would be in that
conversation you know I mean we still
see why John Jeffries you're right
okay yeah sure you're let's let's go
through these names right now it's
Kelvin Benjamin Zay Jones Robert Foster
Andre Holmes Ray Ray McCloud
I guess when one of your guys is named
Ray Ray it's not a good sign but I mean
say Jones was a second-round pick
Simpson yeah Calvin Benjamin was a
first-round pick since I know
I don't know what doesn't mean they're
good doesn't mean everywhere where is a
Jones
what kind of receiver is a Jones who
else does he remind you of gosh it's
it's hard he's I don't think he can ever
be the outside receiver where you're
gonna go oh you could be our outside guy
you'll attract attention no I think he
has to be he is I think it is very peak
he can be Brandon LaFell Wow that's who
he is it's not a great piece no but like
let's LaFell like he can work the middle
of the field move throughout runner but
I'm never gonna make a lot happen right
all those guys are not doing quick cut
nothing and you know he's doing
interception in the game Josh Allen I
mean he threw the ball perfect it was a
perfect throw Andre Holmes first of all
didn't get back to the ball and the ball
went off his face
so you it's hard to evaluate Allen it's
really hard to evaluate the Josh's in
general and we'll get to Rosen em yeah
this but that's very hard Buffalo
defense explaining how they stopped
Tennessee's offense
I didn't realize they're the team that
got Jordan Phillips from Miami and now
you right they have four defensive
tackles yeah I mean you look at their
front line Kyle Williams star luteal a
Lee Trent Murphy Jordan Phillips
Harrison Phillips Shaq loss and Jerry
Hughes but those four guys Williams
luteal a Lee Phillips and Phillips
that's what you were just talking about
having the big guys gotta have those big
guys you gotta have at least you really
have to have four on your roster because
you have to have two in there at a time
unless third and long but you have to
protect yourself from oh they're gonna
spread us out and run it up the middle
oh you know yeah they're gonna come in
with a three tight end set we think
they're gonna throw the ball damn they
spread out now we still have to protect
them but whatever it is you got to worry
about that had you not seen the Nick
Williams drop touchdown before the film
oh no I had not seen I was was with
Fender ik and Tennessee that was our
opportunity to score a touch on the
first real touchdown on the game other
than Josh Allen did you lose your mind
for that one I I just I was hitting
Fenric going that's the most egregious
drop of a touchdown I've ever seen I was
pretty bad
Mariota rolled out put it right in his
hand yes man yep that was a big play but
you don't think Tennessee's offense
makes sense no I'm not I'm not
in love with Tennessee's offense right
now first of all the interior gets their
ass whooped and even their tackles
aren't playing to their capability on
Conan Willa Juan have not been as good
this year as they have the last two
years behind that so there's a
fundamental issue up there
the interior the offensive line gets
their butt whooped all the time and I
think Matloff lures and offensive
coordinators kind of still finding his
way and he's finding a way of how do he
wants to use these pieces I'm sure mark
this is a new learning experience for
Mariota I mean again you know we're
defending Mitchell true Brisky and him
learning his you know second offense in
two years here at mariota's this is a
new offense for him it says I guess his
second in four years right but
regardless III would argue I would I
would have bet that this offense is far
more complicated than the one he ran
with malarkey especially with some of
the passing rules and things like that
but yeah it's just disappointing them as
often there's no flow as I talked about
I don't really know what they're trying
to accomplish on offense they didn't
have a flow against Philly you know they
really didn't you know what more
sporadic big play exactly to me right
now it's always when I go back to it's
just the rolodex like oh yeah I got all
these plays they're great I'm just gonna
roll through it no this is the one I'm
gonna pick for this play and that's not
what the great o'seas do they know how
to tie plays together
set them up McVeigh's running this play
this is the third time he's run this
formation cuz he's just waiting and he's
trying to bait you to get into this
defense because then he's gonna screw
you with this when you were saying
Monday that Andy stretched out
Jacksonville at the beginning of the
game I thought that Josh McDaniels did
that to the Colts in the beginning Liam
- like when I watched braid in the
beginning of the game he'll throw like
an out route - Phillip Dorsett and I go
there's no way he throws that the rest
of the game yeah but he throws it in the
first quarter to open up the middle of
the field and it always seems like a
flow yeah the good offenses are an
assault assault assault on every aspect
of your day that's right they take away
your aggression and that's what I think
that when I see I go Tennessee I go man
it's a lot of repetitive concept it is
it is it's a lot of I've seen that
formation on a few times right you know
yeah all right leather Josh Josh Rosen
Arizona versus San Francisco could it
have started any better 75 yard bomb the
Christian Kirk and
better than the throw was the feet yeah
and the eyes on the crosser so we're
back to feet yeah but I always thought
Josh Rosen had good feet he done he did
but this one was more about he didn't
you get coached in the NFL at the
quarterback position you're bored with
this podcast today aren't listening
intently he as a quarterback there's
always especially listen to your feet oh
we're gonna throw the post route you
know it should be two hitches and then
if it's not there by that second hitch
move on to your second read whatever it
may be
okay listen to your feets good but you
know what [ __ ] listen to your brain
in your eyes too sometimes you're just
gonna go home I hold on to the third
hitch step it's gonna be an 80 yard
touchdown so screw listening to my feet
you have to have a balance there a
little bit and what he did was exactly
that I think he took four hitch steps
but he stared down the crosser he made
the free safety go oh he's gonna throw
the deep crosser and he took the extra
hitch step to go I'm just gonna let this
develop just a half a second more here
so I can make sure the safety does jump
it and the guy does clear him over the
top and he did that and I mean come on
man that's your first throw as a starter
on the road and your history your game
that's amazing
I wish I always want my team to throw
deep on the first drive yeah like I feel
like every offense should throw deep on
the first drive just to at least go that
could happen yeah yeah I know I think
that is it happens then great
I just don't waste your best play on the
deep throat okay what do you mean well I
just mean because sometimes quarterbacks
aren't rhythm yet you're still excited
yeah and like I was always like like
cauliflower first play yeah I mean I get
that way somebody did that this week
damn I can't remember who the Patriots
Ralph somebody called a flea-flicker to
start oh the bills that is right Josh
Allen you dish that's when you know your
team's not very good when you're calling
the flea-flicker to start the game
you're going please help us soften a
prayer I the deep shot thing I agree
with you you have to do that just to
show the defense for just want to go and
just throw it to the end but I was sure
something like that I never wanted of
our great play-action passes to be
called right there though because I just
wanted to be like I want to feel the
game a little first you know
oh so you're and I've always wanted
waste those plays always I didn't
suggest play action I just said I've
always wondered this so when you're
doing play action you turn your back to
the defense yeah right and you fake that
hand on right there's definitely that
party that's like when I turn around I
hope they bid on that [ __ ] so hard like
obviously you're going when I turn
around I hope that Jordan Phillips isn't
in my face that's the first thing but
you're also going if I look up and that
things there it's gotta be one of the
best feelings ever it's amazing it's
like jackpot like oh my god I hope I
don't [ __ ] this off with this throw I
mean yes it's amazing this is my
favorite plays always were you know we
call them
ex-special with Joey Galloway where I
just was like damn they're not gonna be
writing this we actually had a read
where if the safety was within 20 yards
that are 18 to 20 Joey was gonna run the
post if they got deeper than that he was
in a curl up at 20 so they could never
be right and then I just go okay just
Joey find a hole that I'll throw it as
hard as I can and fit it in there yes
but I never wanted to waste those
players to start the game for two
reasons okay I want to get him rhythm
yeah other thing is a lot of the
receivers don't run full speed at
practice all week like that's they don't
like you know like Odell Beckham jr.
can't go out there and run for three
every play of every practice okay that
makes sense you know what I mean so
there is that first part of the game
where you go okay I'm juiced up and
they're getting their legs right now
they're like ready to go cuz they
haven't ran hard the last two or three
is let me get a little gauge for how
juice how much juice they got you still
need to see how fast a little bit yes so
can you tell when a team is about to
bite on a play-action
like can you tell when they're like man
they're really starting to bite on a lot
of stuff right now
definitely yeah and then are you like
are you like how would you look at the
cylon and be like play-action yeah yeah
you would because you're not gonna call
for a play no I mean if I'm out there
and doing it I mean it's gonna be hard I
might run over to the sideline but hey
thirty is like totally peeking in the
backfield right now which is what I
would imagine the conversation that
happened on the Seattle sideline with
Marcus Peters this week yeah we'll get
to that too but that's the kind of thing
you do you usually have somebody on the
side and I know looking for that the
quarterback coach he's been a point
during the week and when I call these
plays just check out the safety if he's
getting aggressive I'm gonna call these
plays to kind of back him off or
whatever can you tell if one of your
receivers is slower like if Joey
Galloway hasn't been warmed up yet do
you have to take a little off the ball
until he has his legs yeah definitely
you can you can it's noticeable you can
it's noticeable it was it's more times
or not though the other way around where
you're just like Tim he's been cruising
all week at practice and now yeah now I
took my time on a long drop back
thinking let me let him get down the
field and he look up and I'm like oh
[ __ ] he's already 70 yards I can't throw
it any farther you know that's where you
just go oh crap and that's where I
always a scared of those big plays early
on to finish off Rosen I think of all
the quarterbacks he comes in second to
Baker in terms of how you were impressed
by him this week Rosen's motion is so
efficient he doesn't need a lot of room
in the pocket
he's very calm he's comfortable in the
pocket he's always looking for the big
completion on his incompletions to be
honest no one's open he had two misfires
in the flat but this was the line Josh
this was the line that caught my
attention me Joshua Josh Rose I'm
working on my Steven Naismith pause okay
so the pause there so what I saw Josh
what I saw from his note that really
caught my attention not good it's hard
really uncomfortable Sims wrote he's not
gonna wow you with a with athleticism
but his subtle movement in the pocket is
like Brady yeah so you like his feet
even though he's that and that was your
issue with him in the draft he's not
gonna outrun anybody but you loved the
way he's in the pocket you're writing
he's comfortable he's come and his feet
are like eyes are down the field and
he's doing it with like the sixth sense
you know just like he's looking at life
as Gerald's run the deep cross but he's
also while looking at it has a good has
fuels that the defensive tackle is about
to hit his upside shoulder so let me
slide up in the pocket and also move to
the right why I'm doing it because the
other D tackle is coming straight at me
and he could still do that feel it and
throw the football accurately and see
downfield yeah those are little things I
look at just go oh there's kids and he's
a natural in the pocket he really and he
really does try and and and throw the
big play
he's he's aggressive that's that my new
thing I think this year the good
quarterback suspect and these young kids
they're aggressive like this again we're
gonna get through in a minute but this
managing the game [ __ ] it's over it's
over you're being silly if you think
that's the way to win this day and age
in the NFL are you referencing well Alex
Smith particularly it was who was
referencing there but this day and age
where we're just talking about where
it's a garbage and touchdown like
breakout year this is not the year to be
Charlie check down or manage the offense
it's the year to go for big play right
right yeah that's why Tyrod Taylor it
looks completely different team than
Baker made exactly makes you wonder what
the Browns what could be right now if
Baker was playing the whole time
especially when you see it what teams
did this seem to the Saints yeah you
cool if I put Rosen has Brady like
pocket presents in a headline yeah let's
get to the Peters thing that you were
talking about you wrote Peters is
peaking in the backfield way too much
late that's what happened on the Lockett
touchdown you said it was constantly
throughout the game constant I mean it
was even on there was a few third downs
where you know he's got the little slot
out round and he's peaking in the
backfield like he's trying to look where
Russell's look at he's always done this
he's always done this I feel like it's
worse than ever now it's actually
affecting like his backpedal and his
technique and things like that I think
they've allowed 84 points in the last
three games the ramps yeah is it a
systemic issue or is it just individual
plays like that that are allowing big I
believe it's systemic issue yeah I had
no problem with what their defense is
doing it's just been a mistake by a guy
here or there and it's been him several
times really the last few weeks where
you just go come on man like you know
just play your guy stop you don't it's
not always gonna be a pick six there's a
time to take those chances that's what
happens when you get a pick six I know
one the rest of the year yeah yeah you
gotta balance it and he's been known for
that and that's he's been amazing at it
but he's getting burnt for it right now
at the same point you said the Seattle
run game is real it is real it's the
last is not just a fluke that they've
been really sticking with it running 30
times a game and they ran all that ray
ran well against Arizona yeah
they ran well again
Dallas exactly right so there's three
weeks in a row three weeks in a row it's
real you think that their offensive line
which has been much maligned for the
last few years the size of them you're
seeing right now is it's it's really
good with this shot in higher off at
Sean hi my office yeah and I'll say what
Mike Davis runs hard
they both do Carson's healthy he's gonna
run a home right they run that's the way
I don't look at them and go who they're
really talented I just go man they got
good vision and they run hard as hell
I'm hoping yeah the impact that Tom
Savage had on deshaun Watson yeah where
Tom Savage isn't a great quarterback but
he throws hard and it calls to Shawn to
throw harder right that I'm hoping Mike
Davis can have that impact on Rashad
Pentium II take you go listen you're
really talented guy yeah killed it at
San Diego's today here's a deal you got
a run in another level yeah I think I
think you're what's what I mean if you
read what Pete's been saying over the
last few weeks I think that's exactly
what it does I need him to wanna he
needs to want it and he went through
training camp and then got hurt and he
got out of shape it sounds like a little
bit and yeah now he's behind he'll get
his chance again
and he's gonna be foaming at the mouth
when it does happen and we'll see what
he's made up but to your point with the
offensive line hey Shawn himer this is
why I was glad he was the OC this is if
there was anything to say positive about
Brian Schottenheimer as an OC it's his
run game it's real and he has some
interesting concepts they're old school
and damn with Britt at center felucca at
right guard huh a Fetty at right tackle
Dewayne Brown at left tackle yeah
they're banned junior Swezey they are no
smaller is a molar they're all ballers
where I just go yeah I mean if you're
all then pass inspection is an issue yes
it is an issue but it is funny because
look I like teams that Zig when everyone
else sags yeah and because we're in a
throwing league playing Seattle is
almost like playing Georgia Tech and
football you're not gonna see a team
that runs 32 times and you know what if
you're not used to pounding and they are
yeah hey I know it's like Jets Broncos
right oh you're right I mean I'll go
back to a court I heard Jon Gruden say
in the training camp to Derek Carr is
okay but this league that rules the way
other right now guys defense the players
can't even practice tackling so I'm
stupid if I don't run Marshawn Lynch a
bunch of times
I love
Mike Davis I'm gonna South Carolina yeah
bowling ball he was a bowling ball he's
better than I thought he was gonna be
I'll say that that's why I like Nick
Chubb there's some guys that when I see
him at the combine I'm like that dude is
just made to get low and I agree I might
be but you were right about Nick jump I
might have been wrong about that one too
Oakland offense Chargers defense Jalen
Rashard is the second best running back
ahead of Doug Martin yeah it's I don't
they're wasting carries with Doug Martin
I don't know what other way to say
there's no polite way to say it I know I
just look at this and go when Doug
Martin was in his prime Jon Gruden was
living in Tampa Bay and saw how good he
was and he has a love affair with him
and he just hasn't got over the fact of
what he is now as a reality I so they
have had the two guys DeAndre Washington
and Jalen rashard now for like three
four years right and both of them I find
to be great change of pace back yeah but
if you've watched the Raiders the last
few years you need to know that Jalen
rashard is a special running back yes he
is a great receiver of the ball he's a
ping pong ball that goes off everybody
right he is a perfect complement to
Marshawn Lynch he really is yeah I don't
feel like Jalen Rashard has been used
tonight for the Raiders for the last few
years I agree and I don't know carries
are giving to Martin they should be
giving to Rashard it should be the
Rashard and Marshawn Lynch show yeah all
the way you also wrote martavis Bryant
is back yeah he is I mean like again I
don't give a damn about the stats I look
at you know the movement at the line of
scrimmage the setting up the DB and the
extra gear all running right the extra
gear whether it's opening up or the
ability to accelerate he's still in the
Raiders I know and he he looked as good
last week cuz I I really think it's as
good as he looks since that year in
Pittsburgh I really were the suspect for
the suspension where I just said man
martavis Bryant like teams are gonna
start looking at him and going ooh we
got to be careful about how many times
we leave our guys one-on-one but now his
issues are minimizing the mental mistake
yeah not fumbling the ball so huge I was
an enormous fumble as it was but
martavis Bryant as a whole it's that
element that they can add to that
offense an offense that you wrote is
good right it's not the Rams it's not
the Niners and Kyle and you wrote the
offense needs to carry the T
were five weeks in not as a team as a
whole what's your view of Gruden's
office Rudin's offense it's good it has
everything you want in it
am i blown away did I think we would see
a few more things creatively yes I did
I'm not gonna lie about that but I still
put Gruden in that next tier of guys
certainly there's no illogical plays
they don't waste plays he doesn't run
the ball into bad looks those are all
things I look at first off to just go
wait is this even realistic what he's
asking is seem to do because if you do
too many things unrealistic like damn
you got six blockers and you're running
the ball at eight guys then I start to
go you're kind of stupid I don't know
what you expect to happen he doesn't
waste plays like that so yeah I'm not
gonna say here I'm like you know jaw
dropped but it's still really good my
point though with their offenses they do
have to carry the team that their money
is on the offensive side of the ball
who's 5th ranked offense the NFL right
now who's being paid on defense nobody
who gives a damn about their defense
they don't got any pliers so they need
to win like we saw them win a few years
ago when Derek Carr was on pace to win
the MVP which was shootouts yes fourth
quarter Derek Carr magic on Thurs gotta
take more risks as what you're saying
III think so I yeah it risks but either
way the offense can't blow their
opportunities we can't have martavis
bryant fumbles we can't have
interceptions at the one 1st and goal
that's worse than like just an
interception of the one when it's first
and goal yeah you don't need to force
anything right you got three more shots
what are you doing this is second time
in three weeks he's thrown an
interception on first and goal job of
the Dolphins game right that was first
and goal fade why there's no what's
crazy as they had that game I know so
defensively about the Raiders you wrote
you expect Conley to be benched for
Worley yeah I do I eyed the writers
entirely first yeah first-round pick two
years ago what do you mean when I'm
going on I just they're rotating corners
at a pace where I just go there's
obviously an issue here you know he's
not playing that but he's playing that
bad yeah yeah he's not been good he is
not and I mean yeah I know he dealt with
the shin splints and whatever else for
like a full year for me just
what I saw at Ohio State he is missing
sixth gear in fact I would say you might
be missing fifth - he's only got one
through four right now and yeah he's a
liability set up a lot of big plays and
I you know Darryl Worley came back from
suspension and he looks good and they
might just trust him more right now but
you know the Raiders defense man I mean
it's the Raiders defense yes there's
nothing there and you also said they
have a lot of receivers at LA for the
Chargers but you did write that Mike
Williams has becoming a go-to guy he
really is when he shows his full
athleticism I go he was seventh pick in
the draft him and Corey Davis are very
similar to me when they show the peak of
their athleticism when Corey Davis takes
a corner and plants him in the earth
yeah where Mike Williams jumps over
somebody I go that's why you went to
exactly right and as is are you seeing
Rivers trusting Mike Williams I do yeah
I especially like I always look at the
imagine in the red zone yeah the red
zone even in the middle of the field
like he's trusting him to like sit in
the right area and I'll throw the ball
high here and you'll go up and catch so
he's not above Keenan but is he now
above totem I feel like it's very close
I am during the game I start I there was
a few times Rose like where's Tyrell
Williams like what's happened here like
you know and he's still caught a few
balls Keenan is there mr. everything guy
then Tyrell and Mike Williams get more
the tougher Travis eventually goes deep
right and he's not even back healthy yet
so it's a beautiful setup and then
Antonio Gates is only red zone I will
say this I will be contrarian everyone
loves to freak out when Jon Gruden says
I need a better pass rush how could he
say that held not self-aware Khalil Mack
you traded a baba wawa look Jon Gruden
traded Kaleo Mack but is he not supposed
to say that he needs more from his
password great what is he supposed to
say oh we need more you know what I did
treat Khalil Mack I shouldn't have done
that
yeah how dare I ask you guys arrested
look there's he needs more from the guys
that he has but he can't say that that's
not an issue right now
he's just openly saying it but for a lot
of people how unselfish
look I don't know what to tell you they
were not gonna pay Khalil Mack a hundred
million dollars they didn't think that's
they needed I understand that he's out
there and Khalil Mack has more
statistics than the Raiders do as a
whole defense in some categories but
some franchises aren't built to pay that
much money no they have an enormous
contract to Coletti assembly they have
an enormous contract a derrick karr they
don't know what they're gonna do with
Amari Cooper they gave a lot of money to
Donald Penn they gave a lot of money to
Rodney Hudson they gave a lot of money
to the other guard like they spent a lot
of money on their gate Jack's a lot of
money on the three interior guys and I
said I mean the offense has to perform
that yes oh yes so the thing is is they
had a lot of money allocated and then
they just decided you know what we're
not gonna be able to pay Khalil Mack
which I don't think was a smart decision
but that was their plan
it was their I don't think they could
legitimate lipe them and that's the
thing is I think also there's a money
issue with the Raiders right I don't
think they had the liquid cash to go
here's the 40 million dollars right I
think it's Madden and that there isn't a
business owner running a franchise right
that also goes listen I don't want to
pay that much money this year yeah
people think that it's just you have
that much salary cap left you will use
it and these owners are going I don't
need to spend forty million dollars if I
don't want to because I'm making the
same on refreshments and ticket sales as
I did last year for what to finish
because they don't know I know I just
think sometimes people think of touching
bags yeah and then it's oh john grew
john weren't allowed to say that his
current pass rushers can improve their
passing he's also allowed to say that
his quarterback is pressing in certain
situations and everybody looks at it
like is this cryptic talk no this is
[ __ ] Jon Gruden he wears his heart on
his sleeve and he can't help it watching
the film looking at Derek Carr listening
to them and having played for Jon Gruden
where do you think the relationship is
right now between Derek and John I think
it's I would bet it's fine I would bet
you John is complaining a little bit
about him behind closed doors to people
I think he's saying it to his face um I
think he's saying what he's saying in
the media and he makes his point in the
meetings when he just you know he'll
watch a play like that and be
disgruntled and Huff a few times huff
and puff and it's a few decision make
just say
that car is making yeah he probably
still likes his physical abilities I
think of without a doubt you know let's
not forget the quarterback coach that's
there with him to Greg Olson he was the
OC when they drafted Derek Carr so I
think they're they're like Derek Carr
I'm not worried about that but Gruden
yeah he's not just gonna give you a free
pass because he likes you he is that
kind of guy I mean I will say this you
do look at them they did they were
driving up and down the field against
the Chargers have been a few critical
errors yeah they did hang we must closer
than yeah they did hang 45 on a
Cleveland Browns defense right now and
shown to be already good and the
Dolphins game I mean he put up almost
200 yards with Jordy Nelson alone they
were there yeah they were there there
could be a totally different season
between they have and they had chosen a
ten-point lead on the Broncos and
completely let that send a fullback drop
the ball on fourth and one that was a
changer uh I believe that's it you did
watch Miami Cincinnati and I'm sure that
you looked at that and went wow Miami
had this game 17 and nothing
Cincinnati is one of those teams like
here we are going Miami's gonna be
frauds Miami's gonna be frauds but if
you really look at Cincinnati this
season you love to say the Colts were
driving down the field to beat the
Cincinnati Bengals they got the Ravens
on Thursday night they got blown out by
the Panthers the Falcons we know what
their defense is so I was an out duel
there they still allowed 36 points to
the Falcons yeah and they were down 17
nothing to the dolphins yeah and he did
to freak plays to land in their
defensive lineman lap I'm just saying
I'm probably gonna take the Steelers
next week I'm just saying I'm probably
the Steelers that - Lee yeah against the
Steelers I've still like Cincinnati okay
- Cincinnati was the better team on the
field on that game - okay
they were so don't worry yeah 17 nothing
was deceiving really Miami put together
one drive and had yaqeen grant return
her to yard punt right so the game was a
lot more even than you think you also
got to remember and we just pull up the
stats because I know there was a there
was a oh the intercept and II dog do an
interception in the red zone Rashad
Jones made a good play I don't know why
Andy threw it the ball got tipped in the
air I got intercepted intercepted so
those were changing or you know changing
of how the game was played tight moments
I am so concerned with Miami's offense I
get that's where I wanted to go with
this more than anything
Tannehill know it's just I had to
actually gay
it's just lack of good enough stuff it
really is I think that's what bothers me
their old line has issues past walking
that's a real thing when Laremy Tunsil
went out of the game yeah oh my god Ted
Hills underrated and he had no chance
well I mean when he threw those picks to
the defensive linemen he was a cluster
it was a cluster I mean Geno Atkins was
unblockable happy to have it really is
awesome and he's good cuz he's yeah he's
like the first Aaron Donald and got hurt
and people forget that he was like the
first area Donald but yeah he was
amazing
uh yeah the Bengals got talent and we
know though we made it as Marvin Lewis's
best skill William Jackson
we just that's another one William
Jackson an Xavier Howard in that game
they're amazing they're amazing those
are two corners that get no love they
get no love William Jackson has
surpassed Dre Kirkpatrick as the best
corner on that football team if I think
I both was pretty I know I mean but I
mean William Jackson is really a guy I
look at and go oh this is like he's
special he really is so we're seeing the
league I mean I got a probably sit down
with my DB thing because I know I made
my xav inheres in the top five
conversation I'm I think I feel
confident that William Jackson's at the
very least in the top ten okay convo
there and maybe I come up with a list of
these guys again Josh what college did
William Jackson attend they were a
top-ranked school that wasn't expected
to be there the year that he kicked ass
Houston now admit did you cheat no I
didn't know I just pay attention during
our draft coverage I got my gmail open
here I'm taking notes why don't ya check
out the other ten I thought oh I didn't
see anything I got on track all right
that's it good film breakdown this week
thing is there anything else that was
going on that you really want to talk
about no did you really think I would
have been able to type William Jackson
without you noticing you're right with
the sound of your computer I'm like
breaking the
yeah because you were so good I'm gonna
give you 60 seconds on the environment I
don't know what you guys read today you
were very emotional would you like to do
that well I just just it's 80 degrees
and it's the middle of October that's
the first thing I'm a little weirded out
that nobody can I mean even you have
said something about it the last like
weaker say like it's 80 degrees and 65%
humidity every day in the month of
October
yeah I'm sweating on the train ahead
buddy thinks there's anything wrong with
that and I know there's nothing wrong
with that when you compare it to the
last five to eight to ten years but I
can tell you when I was growing up in
October and I mean in high school I
wasn't playing football games in October
that were 80 no I remember like at Rex's
they were I remember trick-or-treating
in October and it being like really cold
yeah like fall I just and then there's a
bunch of reports that came out this week
so were they well I mean the United
Nations who met last week they're huge
climate change report came out and like
listen this is now there's no more hoax
or hypothesis year we know so because we
know and a lot of our listeners agree
yeah what are some things that Chris
Sims does to help the earth that our
listeners can join in oh well Chris
drives a Tesla first of all I don't know
these stories probably can't do that I
mean but go for a more eco-friendly car
Oh eco-friendly car okay beans not beef
are you so explain that to people well
like beef cows it's one of the
number-one polluters of our air that
there is because every time you hear a
cow go hmm that's methane that comes out
of their mouth but how does that not
eating them well because then we won't
have to waste let's say 80% of our
farmland on just cows what you think
that if we not only are we eating that
they're eating the grass and the things
that help out the atmosphere they're
polluting the atmosphere because we've
become the greatest carnivores on earth
the American male who has to have meat
rat meat three times a day or they're
cheated as an American it's just not
realistic so that's an issue all right
don't leave all your lights on around
your house my wife she has an issue with
this it's like I come home and I'm like
damn we had high alert is this North
Korea coming like and so you use less
like tribe yeah I go around and like
flip all the lights off so I try to be
be efficient there okay one more little
nugget that people can do to help the
earth mass transit will always help
they're not driving an eco-friendly car
what else am I trying to think of here I
wasn't ready for doing recycle of course
I mean to the extent where I won't even
throw away my plastic bottle until I see
a recycling thing in New York City I'll
have an empty bottle like hanging up the
pocket of my bag cuz I'm like I'm not
throwing that in the trash
this is recycling I'm putting it in the
recycling I mean what's wrong I mean I
don't know I'm just trying to be a
better human sorry I'm trying to think
of anything else that you do but the
head of NASA the UN climate everybody is
coming out and going this is a huge
issue we need to act we know okay this
is not like hypotheses and we have one
group of people in our country okay and
I'm not trying to get personal we have a
group of people in our country who
really know the only people in the world
that don't want to accept this matter
they're the only ones everybody else is
on board and going huh this science
thing they're onto something yeah and
that was the environment with Chris Sims
recycle take mass transit get an
eco-friendly car turn the lights off on
your home and those plastic bottles you
better make sure they do Josh you're
great I was that was great timing on the
outro music there okay hit at the
perfect moment yes it's like put on the
outro music before he says so we gotta
get outta here we have our betting show
tomorrow I will get my $20 we will see
how we do I actually spent it so I gotta
go to the ATM to making it rain for Sims
peace out homey for fender good evening
everybody and the lef koe man says holla
holla holla holla holla
check out youtube watch the show Sims
and Lefko we gave to Rico and up their
Mitzvah if you miss it you're missing
out
[Music]